Joining me today is a New Zealand born
author,
speaker and founder and head mistress of
Mckayla community school,
a free school established in London all
the way back in 2014.
Catherine verbal saying welcome to the
Rubin report.
Hi.
I'm very happy to have you here.
Thank you for having me.
I've heard a rumor that you sometimes
play my videos in your classrooms.
Well,
I don't know about the classrooms,
but among staff,
among staff in the school,
somewhere in this school,
in this school definitely,
um,
were already fans.
Thank you.
Far too controversial to play in the
classroom.
Yeah,
I think so.
There's so much I want to talk to you
about,
about education,
your,
your personal,
sort of political evolution,
all the things that you've been through.
So I always like finding out a little
bit about somebody's history at the top
and you come from a long line of
teachers and some interesting background
stuff.
So tell me a little bit about Catherine.
Well,
I'm coming and my parents.
My father is Indian guy.
Nice.
Nine mom is and Black Jamaican.
I say that because the whole race thing
is important,
you know,
a bizarrely because these days,
people are so much more interested in
who said it as opposed to what is being
said and uh,
you know,
somewhat some random person set up a
wikipedia page for me and there was this
kind of major argument going on between
my detractors and,
and the people who support me.
People that support me wanted the truth
to be there.
The people who didn't like me wanted it
to,
wanted me to be Indian rather than black
because black was kind of a bigger
victim.
And to discredit me,
they needed me to push me up the victim
pole,
you know.
So my head hard following the
oppression,
Olympics,
the whole operation of it.
Yeah.
No,
exactly.
And so,
uh,
you know,
my,
my mother was a nurse,
my father taught at university and,
and came from,
you know,
dirt poverty in Ghana,
but is one of those extraordinary people
who made something of himself through
hard work.
And um,
I was born in New Zealand and then I
grew up in Canada and then I've now been
in London for nearly 30 years and uh,
I went to Oxford University and I've
been a teacher ever since and I was a
very left wing teacher,
a very typical teacher in that way.
And I used to write a blog which was
called to ms dot would love based on the
book and films to Sir with Love Sidney
Poitier was in the film.
And um,
I wrote this blog a few times a week.
I'd go home and write about how little
johnny had his money stolen and that
kind of thing.
Things that made me really upset about
the education system.
And let's pause for a second before you
get to get to the point where you sort
of woke up and got in trouble and they
don't have people fighting on your
wikipedia page.
So what,
what sort of education did you have that
pushed you towards leftism or was it
just,
just how it was Kinda like where did
those ideas come from?
Did that,
did that come from?
Did that come from family?
Was it meeting my family?
You know?
Um,
it's really interesting because I think,
um,
ethnic minorities really are small c
conservative naturally,
but because,
uh,
the black vote normally goes to the
left,
uh,
my family was no different from a
typical fam,
you know,
ethnic family in that sense.
And so I was brought up in a,
in a,
in a left wing household.
Why do you think they generally vote
small c conservative or why do they
internally either think it or have been
taught to think?
I think they come from small c
conservative.
I'm a background.
So when I say that,
just the belief in and pulling yourself
up from your own booze,
but your own bootstraps,
um,
hard work will get you somewhere.
A personal responsibility being stoical
when things are difficult,
but the kind of thing that makes people
successful.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I think minorities,
especially the ones who've been
immigrants,
moved somewhere new.
They believe in giving their children a
better life and in working hard in order
to be able to do so.
So it fits with them now.
So you come from a small seed
conservative family,
but kind of voting left.
Yes.
And then that's right.
I'm a teacher so everyone I know is on
the left and I don't speak to any
conservative people because that's how
it is.
There's this big divide and nobody ever
speaks to each other.
I didn't know any conservative people or
the way conservative people thought.
And then I was writing this blog and
that's where I started meeting
conservative people and I say,
meet on my blog.
So twitter didn't exist in those days.
People would have discussions on the
blog comment section and uh,
all these left wingers would come on and
um,
start attacking me and telling me how
awful I was with the stories that I was
writing and how can I judge the
education system as I was judging it.
And uh,
all these conservatives would come on
and defend me and I'd be saying,
the left wingers,
no,
no.
I want to.
Well,
you know,
I'm with you.
I'm a good person.
And they'd say,
no,
you're a right winger.
And I'd say,
well,
of course I'm not on the right,
of course I'm not conservative,
I'm a good person.
So how could I possibly be conservative?
And the Conservatives would come on and
say,
I think you'll find that you are.
And over years of me writing and me
insisting that I was on the left,
I came to realize that I wasn't,
that my instincts,
the things that I valued,
the values,
it was the,
it,
those basic values of personal
responsibility and,
and,
and perseverance and,
and being happy with competition and all
that kind of stuff.
Um,
I,
I liked and then I realized like,
I came to realize slowly and,
and then I met a few people.
So like I met you would be interested
because you're always interested in
meeting people who don't think like you.
I met this guy.
So there was this guy used to come onto
my blog called a British national party
member.
So he was,
he was,
this is,
I mean,
people call it the fascist party,
you know,
and in the day they had a lot more power
than they do nowadays.
And um,
so he was part of the BNP and I would
let him come on my blog,
so all of these kinds of lefties were
outraged.
How can you let them come on your blog?
You need to ban him.
But I always thought just commenting,
commenting,
he would comment and get into
discussions sometimes in the and
sometimes with other people and some of
the left wingers would refuse to talk to
him at all,
you know,
and they get really angry with me that I
should just say you're not allowed to be
on here.
And you know,
he was on there for ages,
this is over years.
And then,
um,
and then I said,
you know,
it'd be really interesting to meet you
because you're very different from
anybody I know.
And so I met this guy and you know,
I mean,
he was a racist,
you know,
I mean,
he was,
you know,
the things that he believed about,
black people and so on.
He was a racist.
But you know,
what I always say is some of my best
friends are racist,
you know,
avenueq ,
the,
the musical with,
you know,
everyone's a little bit racist and
people are racist on different levels.
You know,
sometimes you're really racist,
sometimes you just a little bit racist.
Anyway,
I met with him,
he was wearing a suit.
Is Young white guy wearing a suit and
nice shoes.
And,
and he went and he took me for lunch.
He paid for lunch.
So the racist took you for lunch.
That's right.
That's what so interesting about life.
Right.
And um,
so we went for lunch and he was hobbling
along and I said,
you know,
you were right.
And he said,
ah,
you know,
the thing is I bought this suit and,
and these shoes because I was meeting
with you and you know,
you went to Oxford University and I
figured I've got to get dressed up,
you know,
but the,
the shoes are new and they're really
hurting my feet.
And I thought,
isn't that interesting?
Here's this racist who was taking me for
lunch,
who's wearing new shoes that he's bought
because I've been to Oxford,
you know,
and that's what's so interesting about
life is that it's not as easy as some of
the left put people,
you know,
you're a racist,
you're not a racist,
you're a good person,
you're a bad person,
you're this,
it's not like that.
There's a whole variety of different
ways of seeing people and learning from
people.
And um,
was he able to learn from you after
that?
Well,
we met a second time and you know,
I mean,
when I say he was,
like he was telling me about how that
morning he'd been to see his girlfriend
and they have a toddler and he'd gone to
see her and see the,
the,
the baby.
She wouldn't let him hold the baby
because she knew that he was coming to
see me and she said,
you're going to contaminate him because
you're going to.
Exactly.
Um,
but,
you know,
he was a good guy in so many other ways.
And that's what,
that's what's interesting about life is
what I'd say.
Um,
is that uh,
nobody's perfect and people change their
mind,
you know,
I think about my parents who lived in
the same house for 46 years in Toronto
and um,
there was a man called Mr.
Snow who lived opposite them and when he
moved,
when they moved into the area,
it was all white and he was outraged
because he was a racist and he thought,
no way,
I don't want these people living there.
And over the years,
over the 46 years they got to know each
other and they became friends.
And in the end Mr Snow's wife,
you know,
she,
she got cancer and she died and Mr Snow,
uh,
I had to depend on my parents for a
whole lot of help and,
and my parents loved Mr.
Snow and Mr Snell loved them.
Um,
you know,
things can change,
people can change.
And when Mr Snow died,
my parents moved house because the,
the,
the community they lived in had had died
with Mr.
Snow.
And this was a man who was so racist.
He didn't want them to live there.
You know,
isn't it personally powerful too?
I mean,
I can feel it when you're saying that
when you can accept some people for all
their flaws,
that it actually allows you to figure
out how to grow instead of just othering
them forever.
Even,
even if they might do that to a whole
set of people for awful reasons.
Yeah.
Well,
and they can change people change their
minds.
You know,
I have this quote in my office from
Muhammad Ali that says,
um,
you know,
if a man at 40 still thinks the same way
as when he was 20,
then he's lost 20 years of his life,
you know.
Um,
and,
and thank God we can change.
I mean,
when I think about how I used to think,
you know,
and how I think now,
um,
well that's what life's all about.
Right?
So,
okay.
So let's back up to some of those ideas
because.
So you were,
you were a lefty and then you started
teaching in inner city schools.
That's when you started waking up and
that's what sort of forced you to force
you or led you to write the blog.
What were some of the ideas that you
were seeing specifically that you
realize,
wow,
this is not working in these schools?
Yeah.
So,
so one of the big things that I used to
think before going into teaching and
everyone used to just accept was that a
black kids failed at school because
white teachers are racist.
The system is racist,
the white teachers are racist.
And that's why black kids are failing.
Well,
teachers go into teaching for racist
purposes than anything.
Well,
this is what's so crazy.
I was thinking,
but I've met hundreds,
thousands of teachers,
not one of them has ever said to me I'm
a racist and I want to stop black kids
from,
from succeeding.
In fact,
they are killing themselves,
you know,
working all hours,
giving everything that they can to the
job.
Um,
and I started to question the kinds of
things that the,
the normal,
the normal way of seeing things was a w,
what I was being told.
And it wasn't just that,
you know,
in which we might get into later about
teaching methods and about,
um,
a discipline.
And so on the consent,
we're going to send the whole second
half is going to be on your solution
right now.
We're just with the restroom,
right,
right.
Okay.
So yeah,
I started to question all of that.
And um,
I went there was this a black
achievement,
a kind of conference that used to happen
once a year,
which was about improving black
achievement and how,
what do we do raising black achievement.
And uh,
there was uh,
uh,
labor,
so that's our left a political policy,
black,
a woman MP.
So one of our politicians who used to
run this thing and I went along and I
took one of the white teachers who I
worked with and he was older than me.
He's retired now and he'd been doing
this for 25 years and I've given
everything to the job.
And I took him along and these people
were standing up on stage essentially
saying that white teachers were racist.
And I was so embarrassed.
I was so humiliated that I had taken
this man giving up his Saturday to go
and sit and be told that he's a racist
when he had given everything to these
black boys.
So we worked in this boy's school and it
was mainly black boys in this school and
um,
and I,
I was just,
I was mortified.
I'm so gradually I started change my
mind on these sorts of things and then I
started to see that it has to do with
our expectations of kids.
It had to do with our,
um,
our expectations of parents.
It had to do with the kinds of values
that we were giving them.
So if we were saying to them,
poor you,
you're a victim,
life is so difficult.
You're black,
you'll never be able to get anywhere.
Then it's quite hard for the black inner
city boy to go,
oh,
well,
you know,
actually it's about working hard.
It's about,
we always say at school,
even when it's difficult,
especially when it's difficult,
you do what's right,
right.
And as opposed to saying it's difficult,
I can't do it right.
Except before Mckayla,
that,
that business of even when it's
difficult,
especially when it's difficult,
that,
that value,
that business of believing in hard work,
I didn't see it so much.
Um,
and,
and we would give kids excuses.
We give kids excuses to fail and um,
I wouldn't do it in my classroom and uh,
the kids behave for me and the kids
learned with me and of course I'm not
the only teacher was doing that.
There are teachers all over the place in
their own classrooms.
We're doing that.
Uh,
what I,
what I wanted.
What did the administration think of
you?
Because it sounds like,
you know,
Oh,
we've got you.
And obviously as you said,
you weren't the only one,
but we've got people pushing against the
very.
Because that's the fabric of what these
schools eventually become,
that it's not,
it's not on them,
it's on the system that is ruined these
people before they've even begun.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're poor.
I mean,
I don't suppose people realize what I
was saying.
You know,
I mean,
you're talking to kids privately,
you do your own thing and if kids are
behaving for you and you're getting good
results and then the principal loves
you,
you know,
uh,
it just works and people don't know why
I'm,
and I'm not even sure I realized why,
you know,
you just,
you,
you build up an experience over years
and you know,
what works with the kids and how you get
them on board and how you show them that
you're in charge and,
and then you teach them properly and
they love you for it
and realize that your political
evolution was happening at the exact
same time because it was sort of very
personal in the classroom.
But then that you were evolving would
have been in another sense.
Uh,
because I think that's how it is for a
lot of people.
When people come up to me on the street
or email me,
they're saying,
you know,
something's happening at work.
I'm dealing with this and now it's
starting to make me think differently
about politics.
Or I used to always vote Democrat,
but you know,
something happened.
And my family,
we got
into conversation and now I'm starting
to think something else is a little bit
different.
Well that was the blog.
So it was the conservatives on my blog
that I was realizing I'm agreeing with
you and I'm not agreeing with the left
wingers on the blog.
And it was then that I just thought,
well,
maybe I am just a conservative.
So I accepted it and then,
you know,
accepted the idea of being conservative.
And then in 2010 I voted conservative,
which was a major deal for me.
Um,
and it was funny because,
you know,
after I did that,
I remember this is after I ended up in
the press and so on,
I was speaking to a friend of mine and I
said to her and she's Indian,
and I said to her,
you know,
able obviously you've seen me in the
press and everything and how I voted
conservative.
And she said,
well,
you know,
I have something to tell you capital.
I voted conservative too.
And that's the thing.
People are doing this in the candidate
to it.
It's so crazy.
So I voted conservative in May 2010 and
then in October 2010 I was invited to go
to the Conservative Party conference to,
to give a speech and that's like a
convention.
You guys have conventions here.
And um,
I was a teacher.
I never really took much notice of
political things.
I mean,
I,
I can,
I was a bit naive and a bit stupid to be
honest.
And um,
anyway,
I went along and I gave this speech
which,
uh,
the audience really liked and um,
and then I ended up all over the press.
So this is the speech really.
That changed everything.
That changed my life.
Yeah,
for the worst at the time.
I mean,
I think now I can look back and say it
was for,
for the better in many ways or at least.
Yeah.
I mean I'm,
every cloud has a silver lining and my
silver lining has been,
has been a good one because I've made it
into a silver lining,
but I could have been destroyed by it
quite easily.
I mean,
in the end I ended up without a job.
I was told that I would never get a job
in state education ever again.
Lay out some of the things that you
talked about in the speech.
So I talked about black kids failing and
that I talked about,
um,
I talked about that's not expecting
enough of kids and how we are constantly
making excuses for them and how we
labeled them with things like anger
management or a,
you know,
a dyslexia or,
or,
or all these kinds of labels that we
give the kids.
Oh,
he can't possibly be behave.
He's,
he's got issues.
That's what we always say they have,
they have particular needs and uh,
we have to meet their needs as opposed
to just expecting them to behave.
Um,
everybody has different needs.
Nobody,
we can't expect anything of them.
And that's just the norm.
It's the norm.
So I,
I talked about all of this.
I talked about competition and how it
was needed in schools that kids need to
feel as if they're competing against
somebody else and so on.
They need to feel like they're being
inspired to work hard as opposed to
being indulged and constantly let.
Off the hook because while it's not your
fault,
your parents are divorced,
it's not your fault because you live on
an estate and your black and your mom is
a single mom and you can't possibly do
your homework.
I mean,
I don't understand it,
you know,
like,
and,
and that was because over the years,
you know,
I've visited,
I'd worked for a summer once in South
Africa.
I've been to see schools in China and
Brazil and India and all of these
countries where the kids were far poorer
and yet they were walking five miles
getting to school and working really
hard.
So why was it that those kids could do
it?
And apparently our kids couldn't do it,
you know,
so that was why I questioned it and I
said all of this stuff at the conference
and the Conservatives liked what I said
because nobody ever says this sort of
thing.
And then as I say,
it was out of a job and then I thought,
what do I do?
How does that happen?
So you give this speech,
you're fired the next day.
I resigned in the end,
but it was just untenable,
like the press I was,
I was everywhere.
It was like one of those Hollywood
films.
I couldn't go outside my door because
they were oppressed,
waiting outside to talk to me.
Like I said,
our responsibilities of thing.
Go get her.
This is what's so crazy.
All I said was ultimately I was saying
that the education system was broken and
people wouldn't have that.
And the thing is I do feel it's like the
emperor's new clothes,
which is that,
um,
everybody knows that there's a problem
with the education system,
but nobody's willing to say it.
Uh,
and I,
I got hundreds if not thousands of
emails from teachers all over the
country saying,
thank God someone said something.
Thank you for saying something.
I won't tell you my name.
I can't tell you my name because I'll
lose my job because they're all
terrified.
Right.
So,
so yeah.
So I,
um,
I then thought about the private sector
for a bit,
but then I thought,
I love working with disadvantaged kids.
I love working in the inner city.
This is what I do.
This is what I know,
a knock,
I'm not giving up,
so we had just,
you've had charter schools,
uh,
in America for a long time.
We,
it was only in 2010.
The free schools,
which are charter schools started in,
you know,
there was the possibility of setting one
up.
So I decided to set up my own school and
I got a group of people together and
then we started trying to set it up.
Now this was not easy because I had a
lot of people who hated me.
Uh,
I mean I still have a lot of people know
me.
I said I do think the number's probably
reduced or at least they've just left me
alone.
Actually,
I don't know if the numbers reduced.
I think they just leave me alone.
I think at some point they see that you
keep going,
that's it.
Keep becoming successful.
And then they'll always find someone new
to feed them into scare.
But it's like they,
you know what I mean?
Like at some point they're like,
wow,
we haven't got her yet.
That's it.
And then they run out.
They're not into hard work really.
So they kind of are like possibly an
easier target.
Yeah,
I,
it is.
I am a more,
it's harder now because I'm,
because I have the school and it's
really hard.
Although they do try,
you know,
when we were trying to set up the
school,
I was used to say,
gosh,
it's like we're like making nuclear
bombs.
I mean,
what we're doing is setting up a school.
I mean we would,
we would,
um,
we would have parents evenings.
So first of all I'd be out in the street
handing out flyers,
a running into hairdressers and saying,
does anybody have any children who might
want to go to the secondary school?
And you know,
women will be coming out of their hair
dryers saying,
okay,
I'll have one,
I'll have one going into churches and
mosques and temples and all sorts.
And then we would have a parent's
evening once we had it in the pub and
all these parents were driving.
Our detractors are outside picketing.
They've got posters that saying Tory
teacher,
um,
all sorts of insults.
The screaming obscenities at me calling
me names and we have to hire a bouncer
because we were so worried about the
possible violence.
Um,
and then when I was talking to the
parent,
these should parents finding out about a
school,
that's it.
And they're all poor parents from the
inner city,
right?
So you've got all these black mom's
black,
single mums sitting there trying to find
out about this new school and all these
white middle class people.
And when we say middle class we mean
people with money.
You guys can use it as a working.
You are,
when we say middle class you,
you guys say middle class.
We mean working class.
When I say middle class I mean well off
people.
So these white,
you know,
well educated,
well off people are,
have infiltrated on,
are sitting amongst all of these inner
city people,
uh,
who are wanting to find out about the
school.
And when I'm talking they're standing up
and shouting abuse deliberately because
they're trying to disrupt kinda like
when you do stuff and like the shaking
pennies.
We're going to talk about that because I
know you had a little criticism of the
way I dealt with one of the issues that
are related to education.
We'll we'll get to that,
but yeah.
So,
but let's just focus on that for a
second.
What do you think it is about the
intentions of those people?
I try not to judge people's intentions.
I try to judge their actions,
but bees,
these working class,
and I know you're not into identity
politics,
but they happened to be white,
which you're illustrating here that
they're the ones that are attacking the
black mothers that are trying to take
care of their kids.
What is it that these people.
What do you think they really think?
Why do you think they really are so
invested in keeping everything the way
it was?
They'll domain.
They'll say that they're for helping
these people all the time.
Then they'll look at a system that does
not help these people.
Then someone comes in and says,
I'm going to help these people.
There's a track record of doing it and
they hate you and them.
Yeah,
yeah,
they do.
Um,
and so just so I'm clear,
these are white,
well off people,
right?
These are people who are,
who have everything.
Some of them have been privately
educated,
right?
I think it's because they believe in
making people equal that the state
should make people equal as opposed to
giving people equality of opportunity
because I'm all about giving people
equality of opportunity.
I want to make it so that schools are so
good that everybody has an equal chance
of making something of themselves and
changing their stores.
Right?
That's what I want to do.
They don't like that.
They want these people to continue being
not,
not being successful.
And then they as kind of these,
these white knights in shining armor can
come down and the state can provide you
with money and,
and,
and a free apartment and,
and all sorts of things.
And then they can sit at parties and
feel very good about themselves because,
well,
you know,
I vote on the left and I'm a very good
person to run if it works.
But this is.
So they're not interested in whether or
not it works.
They're interested in feeling good about
themselves and their,
they genuinely believe that the state is
going to make things better for these
people and free schools,
charter schools,
while they are state schools,
um,
the breakup,
the education system,
right?
So the unions aren't as powerful anymore
and they very much believe in the power
of the unions and they want them to have
their collective bargaining and if too
many schools break out of the system and
break up the system than it,
it devalues that power of the unions.
So I think that they convinced
themselves that what they're doing is
right.
Even though there are all these poor
moms wanting to find out about another
option for their child and they're
desperate.
I mean,
when I say desperate,
I've had mothers crying,
you know,
in front of me crying saying,
I don't want my child to get knifed I
don't want.
I want my child to have a decent
education so that maybe you'll have a
chance to get to university.
I just want him to be safe.
Right?
And,
and then people are.
And then what they'll do is they'll deny
that,
that that's the case,
that there are schools where children
aren't safe,
they'll deny,
they just,
they just lie.
Just bold face lies about,
about the system.
So what other kind of pushback did you
get as you were creating the school?
Like what,
what is it like to you?
Okay,
you fill out some paperwork I assume and
now you try it,
you talk to some people and maybe you
talked to some teachers that are
likeminded administrators and things,
but what's that light to go on?
I got to find a building.
I got to find funding.
That's right.
So it's a total nightmare.
Total nightmare.
I mean,
really,
whenever any group comes to me and says
we want to set up a school,
I always say,
okay,
well dig deep,
right?
Because you're going to have to get
every bit of energy you've got to be
able to push through on.
This mean it took us three years.
Um,
and it took us three years to find a
building.
There was so many people against us.
Um,
and as you were saying earlier,
I just kept going and I mean I kind of
had to keep going because otherwise I
wasn't gonna be able to do the job that
I love,
so I had to and eventually we found this
building.
I mean,
so first you apply,
you have to go for interviews,
panel interviews and Blah Blah,
and then you get approved and then
you're looking for a building and oh,
it's just a nightmare.
But,
um,
eventually we got this building,
uh,
which,
you know isn't the greatest building and
when I say it's not great,
you know,
there's no grass there,
no trees,
there's no carpet for the staff.
There's just the old car park which is
used as a playground for the kids,
which is tiny,
you know,
it isn't ideal,
but I always say it's the people inside
the building that matter and we've made
a real go of it.
And um,
and,
you know,
it's,
it's great,
and,
and what is great and everybody really
is great.
And this is where,
you know,
I,
I'm reading,
you know,
I feel really optimistic is that we have
five,
10 teachers from all over the world that
come and visit the school every single
day,
mainly from the UK,
but we get Americans,
Canadians,
Australians,
New Zealanders,
I mean,
and they come because they've heard
about us through social media and they
want to see what we do and then we get
loads of letters from teachers,
from principals who say I taken these
ideas and put them in my school and it's
really helped and it,
and it's made things better for our
kids.
So I feel like we're not just having
impact in our school,
on our kids,
but on,
on kids all over the world,
you know.
Alright.
So let's really focus on what you've
done with them.
Kayla's school that you started in 2014.
There was a lot in,
in the research that I was doing about
discipline really before you even get to
education.
So you guys do a bootcamp before you get
to teach them anything.
You're actually teaching them some
things that purely about discipline and
sort of how to live,
how to behave.
Yeah,
and that's because we believe you
haven't taught them how to behave.
Then you can't give them a detention for
it because they don't know how.
And the reason why they don't know how
is because we know that elsewhere,
they haven't necessarily been taught.
They haven't necessarily learned that at
home.
They certainly want to learn it at other
schools.
Um,
and that's because our expectations are
really high.
And so we teach them.
We have silence in the car doors for
instance.
So that's something people come and they
say,
why do you have to be so extreme?
I'll tell you why you had to be so
extreme because otherwise you've got
kids fighting in the corridors,
bashing each other's heads against the
wall.
Some schools where teachers are scared
to walk through the corridors because
it's such mayhem.
You have silence.
Everybody just moves really quickly to
their lessons.
You've got changeover that takes maybe a
minute and a half.
Children aren't losing loads of time
from their lessons.
I always say 59 minutes out of every 60
minutes in the lesson,
you've got it at Mckayla and we're
trying to catch them up,
you know,
a lot of our kids come to us for the
reading age of a five year old,
six year old when they are 11 years old.
In fact,
I mean,
some of them aren't like that.
Some of them are oxbridge material and
we'll go to Oxford or Cambridge and some
of them need real help so that they
don't leave school illiterate and
innumerate 20 percent of the kids in a
Britain leaves school illiterate and
innumerate right?
Twenty percent one out of five kids now.
And that's functionally.
So it looks like they can read,
but they can't really read.
And this is happening across the
country.
Um,
and it's become normal to expect that
now none of our kids going to be in that
position because,
uh,
we teach them so.
And we teach them in an environment
where the children are able to respect
their teachers.
They loved their teachers.
They thank them for their lessons.
At the end of their lessons,
they say good morning and good afternoon
and so on,
and things that you would never imagine,
you know,
inner city kids,
you,
you know,
if you have an idea in your head of what
Nancy kids are like,
you imagine the boys walking with their,
with the trousers down here in that box
kind of way and,
and,
and girls dressing in a way that isn't
appropriate at our school.
None of that exists.
So you do have a dress code,
right?
Well,
they have a uniform uniform and that's
normal in Britain.
Everybody has a uniform,
but the thing we actually stick to the
uniform.
So you go elsewhere there,
the ties it down,
the shirts around and talked.
They look like a mess.
They walk like a gangster.
I'm always saying to the kids if they
start,
if they ever start bumping like that,
I say you look like a gangster.
You need to start that right?
Um,
and they get it.
They say,
yeah,
Miss,
I get it.
And then they stopped doing it because
we talk about getting to the best
universities,
we want you to get the Ivy League
universities to get to Russell Group
universities in Britain,
and we want you to have,
you know,
you aim for the moon,
you'll land amongst the stars.
That's where we think,
right?
And so they're all really ambitious and
they're all working hard.
Why anyone would be against this as a
concept.
I don't know.
So when you hear pushback against that,
I guess it's that people think it's
presumptuous or something to imply that
their parents can't do it.
Even if often the parents are failing
or,
or the parents just have to work too
hard and they don't have time to do the
things that you're doing.
And I think when people think there's a
racial element to that.
So if you,
if you even address that,
I actually think they have a problem
with it itself.
They don't like the idea of us being in
authority.
They don't like.
They think being an authority means that
we must be Nazis.
I've been called not a Nazi many a time,
which is a bit ironic when you think
that what the Nazis would have done to
somebody like me,
but exactly so and they don't like the
idea of us being in authority and us
being in charge.
So um,
one we're really key on discipline,
but two,
we want the discipline so that we can
teach them properly.
And this is where you referring to what
you said,
I was watching you at the Oxford Union
and you'd said how about how kids need
to be taught properly?
And I was and you'd said they need to be
taught critical thinking and take me to
task the.
Yeah,
yeah.
The thing is,
is that you can't teach critical
thinking,
right?
People are critical in their thinking or
independently minded or inquisitive when
they know lots about something.
And it's only by knowing lots.
It's like the 10,000
hour thing.
You know,
you got Malcolm Gladwell,
you got,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
you got the Beatles,
you spend a lot of time doing something.
You will get really good at it and then
you'll be able to break the rules,
but if you're trying to break the rules
right,
right away,
when you don't know anything,
then you end up with kids.
And this is the,
the public don't realize just how bad
things are,
where kids don't know where Paris is,
you know,
kids don't know in Britain who Winston
Churchill is,
you know,
they genuinely have no idea and that's
because nobody's taught them because
people are anti knowledge.
So the grandfather to like the whole
knowledge movement is,
is,
uh,
ed Hirsch,
and he's an American.
His most recent book is why knowledge
matters,
which I would encourage all of your
viewers to read.
Um,
you know,
education is the most important thing in
any country,
right?
And,
uh,
and that's one of the reasons I'm so
pleased to be talking to you because
people need to realize,
you know,
you,
you can have all your arguments about
free speech and about,
about,
I don't know,
guns and about whatever it is you want.
But if the schools are not teaching
children properly,
then that is the end of any country,
right?
And I'm desperately trying to shout as
much as I can the Dell people to that we
need to do something and we are doing
something.
I mean,
we're doing something.
And other people that were not the only
ones,
you know,
there are other people who were doing
things.
We named Mckayla,
Mckayla after a woman who died of
cancer,
who I used to work with and uh,
she and her own classroom used to do
exactly this and there are teachers all
over America and all over Britain doing
this in their own classrooms.
We need,
we need it to be more than that.
We need entire school districts.
You know,
we need people to get this point.
And when you said about teaching
critical thinking,
it's a romantic view that comes from
Rousseau.
Uh,
so 18th century philosopher,
Rousseau and he said,
you know,
a man is born free,
but everywhere and chains.
This whole idea of,
um,
of,
uh,
you education makes you less free.
This is what the,
the,
the progressive thing.
And actually it selfcontrol brings you
freedom,
right?
It's counterintuitive,
but actually order and structure make
you free.
They allow you to pursue all those
avenues of knowledge basically.
Exactly.
Have sort of center.
If you learn lots about something,
then you're able to apply that knowledge
in different ways.
So I mean,
as an example,
um,
you know,
if,
if you take a math question that a
primary school kid might be given,
uh,
you know,
John has eight cents at the end of the
day,
it's one quarter of what he had at the
beginning of the day.
How much money did he spend during the
day?
Now I think I can do it,
and I think you can too,
and I think you can do it,
is because you've got short term memory
and long term memory and you've got a
whole bunch of math facts in your
longterm memory that you're able to draw
out.
You're able to go quarter.
No,
there's four of those in a hole.
And then you're able to go four times
eight because I know my four times
tables and I can take it to 32.
And then I can do subtraction,
so I can take it to 24 right now if
you're seven years old.
However,
if you have to hold all those facts in
your working memory,
working memory,
can't do it.
You have got to drill and practice those
timetable facts,
for instance,
and put them into your longterm memory
and put those fractions into your
longterm memory so that when somebody
gives you something more complex,
you can go Bam,
Bam,
bring it out and then you've got the
answer.
Sadly,
what happens is people say,
no,
what we need to do is teach them complex
problem solving.
Let's give them that first.
You got to break it down.
What are the bits underneath that you've
got to build up from?
And that stuff is a bit boring because
it's boring and isn't very romantic.
This bag was talking about Rizzo.
So Russo,
this idea with you,
you,
you bring it out of the child,
right?
So they have this phrase which says,
you know,
the mind is not a vessel to be filled,
but a spark to be ignited.
And it all sounds really exciting and
thrilling,
right?
And that's the thing,
it's so seductive it,
it pulls everybody in,
but the reality is that actually what
you need is a whole lot of facts in
your,
in your memory there that you can then
go boom,
boom,
boom and apply.
Now,
that doesn't mean that you're just a
parrot and you just end up learning a
whole load of facts,
which you then can just regurgitate.
You need to apply them and you need to
give children the chance to apply them
and have a class discussion and we do
paired work and selling often in more
progressive places.
They'll do group work,
they'll put five kids,
four kids around the table,
and they do group work and then what
happens is the teacher moves amongst
them as a facilitator of learning as
opposed to the teacher who's driving the
bus.
I always say the teacher needs to sit in
the bus and drive and the kids get on
the bus with you and go.
The more progressive way your.
They're just keeping them on task.
You do that.
Let me come and see you.
You do that,
but they learn very much and then they
don't succeed and then we say it's
because they were black.
It's because they were poor.
What we need to do is give them welfare
and then there'll be okay because that
will make them equal and my point is no.
Fix the education system,
give them an education and then they'll
make themselves equal.
Gosh,
this reminds me of.
So I mentioned that I'm not that good at
math and I remember the day,
I haven't thought about this in probably
15,
20,
I don't know,
maybe literally maybe 20 years.
I remember being in sixth or seventh
grade and we were doing division for the
first time and I remember the teacher
gave us a.
We had a quiz or something and I was
able to do it in my head and I saw they
had,
you know,
the equation and I just wrote the answer
and she gave me a fair.
I failed or I got a zero or something
even though I had all the answers right.
She said you didn't show your work.
And I,
and I remember seeing her,
but I got all the answers right,
and she said,
no,
I need to see how you do you work now.
I didn't know how to do it that way,
but somehow I was able to do it in my
head and I remember thinking that if
that was all necessary to show the work
that at some point I would get to a
place where I would have to do it.
But somehow I had figured out my little
trick first.
But because of the way she kinda just
failed me for it,
he completely turned me off.
Man,
I literally haven't done that in
probably 20 years or something.
That's a total sidebar all together,
but I guess it just goes to show that we
all,
we all kind of learn differently and you
need teachers that can kind of embrace
the way you do it a little bit rather
than just jam it down your throat.
Yeah.
Well you,
you,
which is probably a little bit of the
progressive thing that you don't like in
a way.
Yeah.
What I would say is,
you remember that particular incident
and think that's all it was,
but I guarantee you that had you been
taught properly in the classroom,
uh,
you would have known her methods.
You would have known what to write down.
You didn't know what to write down
because there was too much chaos in the
classroom.
You weren't listening,
you were busy talking to your friend
because she let you talk because she
didn't have high enough standards of
behavior.
That sounds brilliant.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's it because this is just
standard.
This is just what happens in all
classrooms.
And then people think,
you know,
it's mean to make kids behave.
And after awhile,
the thing is,
is that remember there's more of them
than there is of us,
right?
So we're not actually making them do
anything they want to behave.
We're just creating an environment where
they're able to do it.
That's all I'm now there's,
there's the,
there's the 10 percent,
there's the 10 percent on the outskirts
that the detentions and so,
and keep them in line,
right?
Um,
but the vast majority,
you need that tipping point,
the vast majority buy in to what we do
and if you come visit our school,
the kids will say to you,
yeah,
it's super strict and yeah,
we get the tensions,
but you know what,
I get a great education and that's what
I want because I want the opportunity to
be able to change my stars and if you
believe that,
if you believe in equality of
opportunity,
which sadly I think too many people in
education don't believe in equality of
opportunity and if you do,
then you want to provide an environment
where they're going to be able to do
that and um,
and,
and that's what we do and,
and I,
and I really hope those teachers would
come and visit us that they're able to
take from that and,
and,
and do something in their schools.
Yeah.
Well first off,
I told you before we started,
I'm going to be in the UK with Jordan
Peterson for a couple of stops.
So I will do everything I can to stop by
and maybe I can get Jordan to swing by.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
his daughter is Mckayla by the way.
So there's a deep,
powerful thing happened is even
powerful.
Um,
what about the type of kids you,
you've mentioned that there's some
diversity in the type of kids that are
coming in.
How do you guys decide who actually can,
can cut it and who can afford it and
other,
you know,
all of that?
Well,
it's not just who comes to us,
it's the local council that kind of send
kids to us.
Uh,
so they decide who goes into a lottery
and people apply and then they get
picked out of a hat literally,
and then,
and then they come on.
Some of the people,
you know,
some of the kids had,
ended up with us,
didn't even necessarily want to be with
us.
Uh,
they just end up being pushed towards us
because that's the way the system goes.
I mean,
frankly,
I don't even understand the system,
but we had a bunch of kids.
We've got a hundred and 20 kids in every
year,
so it's a pure lottery to get to the
school basically,
if they don't win the lottery,
so to speak,
they're just going into the public
school because at that point most likely
the parents can't afford private school.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
definitely the parents can afford a
private school,
but there's no,
I mean,
you talk about it as if we're different.
I mean like we're just another school.
There's loads of schools like us in that
sense around.
Um,
I mean we are a free school,
but uh,
yeah,
it doesn't,
it's not like we're the free school and
then there's the local public school,
there's loads,
there's lots of schools and um,
and parents will choose us if they want
to.
Um,
and as I say,
sometimes we end up with,
with,
with kids because the system is such
that you have to choose your top five
schools and you know,
you've chosen us fifth,
you probably don't want to be with us,
but in the name of fairness as,
as it always goes,
the people who have chosen as fifth has
just as much of a chance getting in at
the,
got very American there and did it well
because I grew up in Canada.
So it kinda changes.
Um,
but yeah,
so people who don't want to come to us
come to us and people who do really want
to come to us,
come to us and look,
you know,
I call myself the dragon lady and I say,
you know what,
I'm not going to change and if you're
happy to put up with me,
these are the rules and this is what we
do.
So if we hear your phone or if we see
your phone,
we'll take it and we will keep it for up
to 16 weeks.
And that's the way that it is.
Um,
you know,
these smartphones are killing kids.
I wanted to get there.
Yeah.
What do you make of that?
Because it's an,
it's a disaster and in 20 years people
get to know,
you know,
when I say it now,
people say,
Oh,
you're being extreme.
You know,
some schools,
they actually have these phones out in
lessons.
Uh,
lots of schools.
They had them out in car doors and in
the yard and so on.
We have the band completely and I'm even
trying to get parents to take them away
at home.
We know we sell brick phone,
so that phone that you can't access the
Internet so that we try and encourage
parents to give them that.
You want to keep in touch with your kid.
Fine,
I understand.
But you don't need to give them a
smartphone that,
that access to the Internet,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
Bill Gates,
all of those big guys in it.
They don't give their children phones
until they're 15.
They keep them away.
When Steve Jobs in 2010 and the ipad
came out and he was interviewed and they
said,
well,
what did you think about?
What does,
what do your kids think about the ipad?
And he said,
I don't know,
I wouldn't give my kids the IPAD.
He,
they,
they protect their children.
Meanwhile,
our parents had no idea they're saving
up for months.
The give the kids this Christmas present
and it's,
it's,
it's like giving them heroin.
I say it's like playing Russian
roulette,
you know,
um,
who you give anybody access to your
child on this phone,
right?
Weirdo out there,
knows who your child lives,
knows where,
how they go to school,
knows where they go to school,
knows who their friends are.
They get,
I mean,
I don't understand.
Well,
the reason why people do this is because
they don't know and they don't think
about the dangers of not just with
random people,
but also lovely girls who get involved
with the bad boys at school.
Um,
bad boys who might be criminals
elsewhere,
etc.
And they quite liked them and they
wouldn't otherwise know them,
but oh,
you,
maybe he's going to add me on snapchat.
Whew.
You know,
And this is the kind of,
it's terrible.
What about just for attention spans,
because I would imagine you're dealing
with a lot of that from young people
right now.
Massive snapchat,
as you just said.
Exactly.
So you know,
before when they used to watch,
you know,
dallas and dynasty and so on,
at least there was a narrative arc that
went like this and it told a story and
then something bad happened and then it
gets resolved and so on.
That doesn't happen anymore.
You got like 22nd.
I went to the hairdresser's look at this
man's bolthead who ended the little
ditty.
That's what they're watching,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's terrible.
So smartphones are a huge problem for
the inner city and,
but the biggest problem I would say,
our progressive teaching methods that
have infiltrated our schools and sadly
this kind of an idea that you're drawing
something out of the child as opposed to
putting something in and the way in
which over the last 50 years we have
turned away from knowledge as being
really important.
This hits,
of course,
the most vulnerable.
So working class kids,
uh,
in,
in our country,
you know,
that tends to be a black thing in this
country,
in our country,
you know,
in,
in britain it'll be black kids,
but it'll also be white working class
kids will be a variety of different kids
who get hit by this because if you are
from a richer background,
your parents,
you know,
you sit around the dinner table at night
and you have dinner and you talk about
the politics of the day and you learn
about different countries and science
and all sorts of things just through
talking to your parents,
onto your parents,
friends and your uncle and your aunt and
so on.
With kids whose parents are not well
educated,
they don't get that at home.
So they're depending entirely on the
school to give them what they need to be
able to succeed.
And sadly,
because schools are convinced about this
idea of this romance around,
I'm thinking critically and,
and,
and that's not to say we don't want them
thinking critically.
We do,
but you need to give them lots of stuff
to get them to that.
So when I said that at oxford union
about teaching critical thinking,
it's not that you don't believe in
critical thinking,
of course it's that you really,
that's not,
that's not something to teach.
At least at first,
it's that you have to give them all the
breath of knowledge first and then they
will learn how to critically think about
overplays issues.
Fair enough.
I like criticism,
I appreciate it.
And it's,
it's something that we're just,
you having to fight all over the place
and,
and it's that idea of giving them that
equality of opportunity,
see it,
which is what I call I keep coming back
to because I'm.
Have you seen any instances where this
doesn't work?
I mean have there been kids that come
through and just for whatever reason,
this,
this concept that,
that you've built that you're instilling
in all these other students,
it just does not work for them either
because of something about them or the
family or.
Okay.
So I've had to exclude a few children
for knives,
you know that.
But it's something in the inner city
that's a problem.
You know,
when we talk about in the city,
you know,
we've got kids showing up,
young men showing up on bikes with
masks,
carrying knives,
waiting to meet some of our kids,
you know,
this,
this is the inner city.
So there are some of those issues that
can take over,
you know,
but,
um,
but that doesn't mean that it hasn't
worked.
It always works.
The kids always learn more than they've
ever learned anywhere else.
The kids always are stunned by their own
intelligence and what is possible.
Um,
because we show that to them and it's
um,
you know,
and what kind of breaks my heart is that
even those who are conservative,
so you have a,
I watch all your programs and you have
all these great people to come on,
but nobody ever talks about education.
You,
larry,
for instance,
who I love and I think he's brilliant.
He talks about all these things play in
the black community and he has all these
stats that he always comes out with.
And there's that thing where he takes
you apart,
you know,
normally real moments,
but what,
but what he doesn't do,
he talks about absent fathers,
talks about crime,
talks about drugs and so on,
but they never talk about education.
And the thing is education.
That's what black people's fault,
right?
That isn't that the state and the state
needs to be held to account for this
because we spend in britain 80 billion
pounds a year on the state education
system and yet we are failing all of our
kids.
And that isn't right.
We,
we and larry elder and all of these
people who talk,
they need to be able to say,
no,
wait a minute.
There's something going wrong at a verY
low level because you can,
you can talk all you want about personal
responsibility.
But if you haven't got an education,
it's very hard to make anything of your
life.
So is the problem then that in,
at least in the american context,
the answer always is throw more money at
it.
So it's not the real answer,
which obviously we've spent 45 minutes
talking about,
which is why and how you have to clean
up these schools.
But the easy answer is always throw more
money at it if they just need more
money,
you know,
you always hear these things,
will,
they don't have enough pencils and they
don't have enough,
uh,
you know,
other supplies and notebooks and things
and people don't take the next step,
which would be the critical thinking
step up.
It's not about money.
You can throw money at anything.
Yeah.
The irony is they all go on about
critical thinking.
They're not doing any critical thinking,
you know,
if only they would.
But,
um,
I,
I wish you luck.
I mean,
the,
the left really refused.
They refused to recognize there's even a
problem.
Uh,
the right will recognize that there's a
problem,
but they don't talk about it.
So that's What I'm saying about the
people who you interview and so on.
I just wish more people would say
actually the solution is in education
because it really is,
uh,
the,
the black community for instance.
Um,
you know,
would,
would transform if they were given a,
the opportunity to have a great
education.
Um,
and,
and that's not to say that all the
things that larry elder talks about,
about absent fathers and so on,
on a problem,
I mean they are absolutely a but it's
really important to call them out on it
and it's really important to cold out.
You see,
and this is where I would disagree,
you know,
I consider myself a conservative and the
black conservative,
but I would disagree with some of the
black conservatives out there who
refused to recognIze racism as a problem
at all.
You know,
they kind of just dismiss it.
And I would say no,
it is a big problem.
and the reason it's a big problem is
because the left in so many ways are
racist.
you know,
when they want to own us and they want
to tell us how we can vote and they want
to tell us how we can think that is
racism.
And when they refuse to recognize what
works in education,
that's going to help poor kids,
black kids,
white working class kids in britain when
they refuse to look at that.
Well that's racist.
And I'd say it's racist against the
white working class.
The way the white working class or
spoken about in britain is the way that
sometimes black car,
the black communities have spoken about
in America,
which is like there's some kind of
different like they're aliens.
Oh well,
you know,
that's just the way they are.
No,
that's not the way they are actually if
you give them the opportunity,
but you will want to sit around dinner
parties and talk about how kind you are
and how great you are because your
virtue signaling and voting on the left,
you know.
Um,
and I just wish,
I suppose that there were more
conservatives who were speaking out
about this and saying something.
Yeah.
I guess there's a weird reflex for them
where they've been called racist for so
long.
Even though often they are minorities
where they don't want.
I see this.
I definitely see this where they don't
want to use the same tactic.
So what you just said,
right there is such a flip on the way we
think of racism.
I tend to agree with that line of
thinking.
Obviously the people that are screaming
about racism or all the time now are the
people who are racist,
who are racist.
They really are,
and I don't say don't say that lightly
because I don't like calling people
faces,
but they're the ones who are deManding
exact look at everyone based on race and
sexuality and the rest of this have to
call it out,
but I think there's a hesitancy from at
least from sort of where I sit because I
don't want to become what they became.
But I know,
I know you're right at the,
at the core of this
look,
I understand you don't want to say
everything is racist,
but when there is real racism,
you need to plan it out and you know,
the fact is that the fact is that if we
don't call it out,
all of these kids are going to keep
failing,
right?
Uh,
what we don't realize is that all of
these kids are going through school and
are being taught,
uh,
to make sure that they're going off and
voting on the left.
That's how it is like that,
that is the,
that that's how everyone thinks,
like it's so standard in the education
system to,
to think on the left that the few
conservative teaches that there are out
there,
they're quiet,
they never say anything because they're
terrified,
right?
Um,
there is no balance of ford.
and,
and that's really scary.
I think,
uh,
a and for the future of,
of,
of our countries,
we,
we need people to talk to each other,
the stuff that you're always talking
about,
about talking to each other and sharing
ideas and thinking about how the other,
the other side things.
Um,
and,
and I worry that,
uh,
we don't,
we don't do enough of that.
We,
we,
we don't do enough of at school,
that's for sure.
And then those kids turn into adults
eventually,
don't they and them.
And then we just,
you know,
and then they're really pissed at the
system that they believe is failed them
and then they just perpetuate that
through the next generation two and then
eventually that's unsustainable actually
because then you have enough people that
are turning against the system that's
failed them.
It's bEcause no one stood up and did
what you're doing.
But it's interesting because this is
where a good old american classical
liberal,
and I know you guys,
at least in the uk have a better
understanding of what classical
liberalism I think that we do here.
We talked about this a little bit before
that these words aren't getting muddled
and mangled and all that,
but this is a place where to me,
where the government should be
involved.
I'm all for using tax dollars to do the
things you're talking about where some I
think.
I think there are plenty of people that
are american conservatives at least that
want to just cut funding from all of
these things and endlessly cut funding.
AS I said,
I'm not for throwing money at them just
because that's just the easy answer.
But yeah.
Let's figure out how do we,
why is it we use money to empower these
teachers?
And that sounds like that's exactly what
you're doing.
Well,
exactly.
It's the power of bad ideas at the
moment that over the last 50 years,
you know,
60,
70 years ago,
the schools that were out there,
but we're more like our school now.
It's just that things have changed so
radically where knowledge has been
sidelined a,
it's all about skills.
People talk about skills and drawing it
out of the child,
like I was saying.
And um,
we've,
we've lost,
um,
we've lost the purpose of education and
we've lost,
you know,
the ideas that we have about
perseverance even when it's difficult,
especially when it's difficult personal
responsibility,
you know,
if you didn't bring in your homework,
then you are responsible for that.
Whereas elsewhere they'll say,
oh,
well it's not your fault.
You come from a difficult family.
Difficult background.
we're going to give you an excuse.
And if you're constantly being given
those excuses and if later on getting
into university,
there are quotas and if you're likely to
get in because you're black or your
union there,
there's,
there,
there are things that allow you,
oh,
I tick that box,
I'm going to be able to get,
get in with a lower score,
then you start setting those stanDards
for yourself.
Right?
And then we don't,
we all eventually degrade the whole
system because if you let someone in at
a lower level and then also let them get
a job at a lower level or get into grad
school at a lower level of the job,
at a lower level.
Everything else.
Well,
that whatever you've created as a
professional is,
is a degraded version of whatever that
supposed to be.
That's right.
And um,
and that is what's happening,
sadly,
uh,
there's a whole campaign at the moment
in britain for this to happen with
oxford and cambridge university,
uh,
to,
to essentially allow kids.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
it's really sad.
And what the reason why is because they
say,
hey,
look,
there aren't that many black kids at
oxford and cambridge,
we need to fix this.
We do,
I agree.
we need to fix it.
So we need to fix the education system.
We need to fix our schools and make sure
that they're given the equality of
opportunity.
Not that day that I spent at oxford was
such an absolute joy talking to so many
kids just in the streets and just
everybody was so like excited to learn
and obviously they were sympathetic to a
lot of the things that I talk about and,
and all that.
I'm curious.
So I get it sort of on the sciences and
math and that you really want to teach
them the facts on this stuff on things
like history.
Yeah.
A lot of the facts in history.
There are facts in history,
but I.
But I wonder now these days where it
seems like young people are kind of into
socialism or young people are kind of
into communism or marxism,
the rest of it,
uh,
have you found that teaching history has
become oddly say,
oddly political?
I mean,
it,
of course it is political,
but oddly politicized,
so like hitler for instance,
has taught to death,
um,
but,
uh,
say the,
the trustees of communism and so on are
not taught so much or even then so
rarely is,
is,
is so little is taught full stop because
they're not being taught properly in the
classroom because you are facilitating
learning and kids are just teaching
themselves.
I mean that I can't stress how much of
that is actually going on.
Um,
so yes,
things are politicized and um,
children are not able to access the kind
of education that they were able to
access before.
And it's hard because I'll say that and
then people will just deny that that's
what's going on.
Um,
but you can see by if you talk to
university kids at university and asked
them what do they know about the world
and so on,
what do they think they'll tell you?
And you'll see how much they've been
taught,
what they've been taught at school.
Uh,
so a few of them have an understanding
of communism and what it is.
Um,
and that's because they're not learning
it properly at school.
Um,
school is
sadly,
it's,
um,
I wish that there was more diversity of
thought amongst teachers.
So one of the reasons why we watch a lot
of you the ruben report is because I
want my staff to try and think outside
the box.
What I always say is I can predict
everything that you think about every
issue out there.
So if I know that you definitely voted
remain as opposed to brexit with regard
to the european union for us,
or if I know for sure that you would
vote for corbyn,
the leader of the labor party in britain
or if I know I'm,
you know,
what you would have to say about a whole
variety of different things.
Even whaT newspaper you read,
if I can make all these predictions,
there's something wrong with me.
I'm conservative on some issues,
but I'm,
I'm anti guns for instance.
I'm pro choice and pro gay marriage,
those sorts of things that I'm very much
on the left on these other things that
I'm more conservative about,
you know?
Um,
and that's because I'm a thinking
person.
Yeah.
Classical liberal.
I suppose in many ways that one might
say that,
um,
you know,
I'm,
yeah,
the point is I just want people to think
outside the box,
right.
And I wish teachers would and that there
was more diversity of thought and there
is some diversity of thought,
but they have to keep quiet because
they're terrified of making sure that
you get the right teachers.
Well,
in a waY it's,
it's self selecting.
So when they apply,
um,
it,
there are already people who were,
who were somewhat thinking outside the
box,
um,
and then they,
and then they come and I think being at
the school also changes their minds
about things.
They start to think differently,
uh,
because they're seeing what's possible.
Uh,
people can't imagine what's possible
with inner city kids until they come to
our school.
I have visitors,
teachers were visitors there nearly
tears saying,
I can't believe that these kids are so
nice.
Um,
so that's,
that's what we're tryIng to do when the
point the point and it happens here,
you know,
I've been to see a,
so I said ed hirsch,
you know,
some of the schools where they use his
materials and they place knowledge at
the heart of their curriculum.
I've seen some of those schools in the
bronx and in,
um,
in,
in various but queens and so on and uh,
and they're doing a great job too.
Um,
I just wish more of it was happening and
that we could,
we could get a bigger platform to talk
about it because it's just so important.
Um,
but people don't,
people don't get that.
They don't get that stuff.
You think.
so I do.
I think that's why these types of things
are working.
That's why you're half a world away,
you know,
thousands of miles away and you've shown
this,
the conversations that we're having here
to your staff and the amount of people
that are showing up to these live events
now,
the amount of people that are
downloading these podcasts and all that,
it's starting to happen.
Well,
I hope so.
I mean,
uh,
there's,
there's so much to Be had,
you know,
I've known tens of thousands of kids.
People often say,
why do I do what I do because I've known
tens of thousands of kids who could have
been so much more,
right,
who could have been in a position to
change their stars and they weren't able
to because the state is spending so much
money on their education and isn't able
to provide them with a decent education.
Um,
and that's really sad.
Yeah.
I wanT you to offer.
So I know that I have a lot of young
people obviously that listened to this
show,
high school,
sometimes junior high school,
but college,
whatever else,
just for the general young person out
there that's watching this,
that's in a school that's not doing
these things,
that's trying to figure out how to learn
and think critically and get a good wide
breath of knowledge.
But the situation that they're in is not
everything you've offered here.
what would you say to them to just start
doing it for themselves?
You got to take personal responsibility
so you can't be a victim.
Um,
you know,
the whole victimhood thing is just
stoked all the time in schools and uh,
and indulged,
you got to think it doesn't matter where
I am a great,
I haven't had the best luck,
right?
I would have loved to been able to go to
that local private school,
but you know what,
so what I'm going to,
I'm going to sit down and I'm going to
work and I'm going to work really hard
and I'm going to go to the library and
I'm going to find the books and I'm
going to teach myself if necessary.
And I've known kids like this who have
done this,
um,
I've known colleagues of mine and people
who I've known,
they just,
they,
they make it their business to teach
themselves what they need to know and
they need to know that knowledge is at
the heart of it.
You need to know lots of stuff and then
you can manipulate that stuff.
Um,
and then you can be intelligent with
that stuff,
right?
Um,
you can do it.
You can.
The thing is is that it's rare that a 15
year old takes it upon themselves to do
it.
They are,
by definition,
they're exceptional.
Most kids need somebody to guide them
and if their parents aren't doing it,
then I think the school certainly can do
it.
Whether or not the school should,
there are people will say,
well that's not fair.
School shouldn't have to do that.
The parents should do that.
And it's true.
And you know,
what if,
if,
if welfare we're not as generous as it
is.
And so on.
The parents probably would have more
agency and self determination about
themselves and the incredible catch 22,
they would take more responsibility and
they would do something and sadly the
state hits them in both ways,
right?
Because it gives them the heroine of
welfare and then it suppresses them by
not giving them a decent education.
Uh,
and then they Sit around and they talk,
oh,
and they say,
I'm a really good person because I
believe in giving people loads of
welfare and in having terrible
education.
I mean,
how,
you know,
you punch somebody on one side,
then you punch them on the other side.
How on earth are they meant to succeed?
Right?
um,
and the thing is we spend a lot of money
in tax to,
to have a state and I'm a classical
liberal,
so I believe in a small state,
but we do have a state,
let's use it for what we can for the
good,
but we're not doing that.
Um,
and,
and that's what's,
that's what's really scary.
And um,
we,
we need a soul believing in this idea of
equality,
of opportunity and that a teaching
children's self control will make them
free.
Um,
and,
and having,
uh,
an ordered environment where children
can learn will enable them to learn lots
of stuff so that they can then be
motivated to do something with their
lives because they will make themselves
free,
um,
by,
by grabbing that opportunity and,
and,
and it's that agency.
It's that sense of self determination
that the conservatives,
people on the right,
right leaning tend to believe in more as
opposed to mummy state coming in and
looking after it for a un taking care of
you,
because if that's what you aspire to,
then what's the point of living,
right?
Um,
but you know,
you have to teach dead white men,
right?
like one of the big problems we have Is
that they don't want to teach dead white
men because they're dead white men.
And that's a problem,
right?
So they only want to teach.
Recently we had this situation where I'm
in manchester.
These students painted over a mural of
kipling.
So rudyard kipling's poem was up there
and they painted it over and put maya
angelou's poem by maya angelou.
Now I'm a great fan of maya angelou.
I think she's brilliant.
Um,
but one of the reasons why she's a great
writer is because she read a lot of
kipling and she read a lot of
shakespeare.
In fact,
she said of shakespeare that she thought
when she first read him that he must
have been a black woman because he
wouldn't know he,
he had to be a black woman to have
understood the plight of black women.
Right?
Because he speaks to the human
condition,
right?
But he's a dead white male or we don't
want to teach him.
Oh,
kipling.
He was a racist.
We don't want to teach him,
but at our school,
we've got them reciting,
you know,
the poem,
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you,
you know.
Uh,
but at the end of it,
at the end of it,
it says,
uh,
the earth is yours and everything that's
in it.
And what's more,
you'll be a man,
my son and that you'll be a man,
my son.
But what about the women?
How,
how can you not be recognizing the women
on,
in a day and age where men can be women
and women can be met and we can't allow
this poem.
I,
well,
he's obviously speaking to me too,
but there's outrage.
Oh no,
no,
he's only mentioned men,
right?
Um,
it's the most beautiful poem.
Our children learn it off by heart,
right?
But children elsewhere will never have
access to kipling.
Now everyone needs has to be taught
about talk taught shakespeare.
Got to by law you have to be taught
shakespeare.
But the fact is we indulge in
shakespeare,
we love shakespeare because shakespeare
is so beautiful and extraordinary.
And just because he's a dead white guy.
Well,
does that mean that he didn't write
beautifully?
You know,
they're,
they're just some beautiful.
I mean,
you know,
love is not love which alters when it
alteration,
finds or bends with the remover to
remove it's old.
so beautiful.
And you want the children to be able to
access this.
and we teach them other poems like
invictus,
which means an unstoppable.
And one was one of mandela's favorite
poems.
Um,
and you know,
east,
they say at the end,
I am the master of my fate.
I am the captain of my soul.
And all of our kids put their hands on
here when they say I am the master of my
fate.
And there's nearly 200 kids in the lunch
whole olis belting this out and loving
it because they are the masters of their
fate.
Um,
and it's teaching the kids that and
inspiring them to make a difference with
their lives.
Whatever their color as opposed to
saying,
oh,
well there's racism and sexism in the
world,
therefore you're never going to be able
to succeed.
Um,
because I,
you just give up and don't worry because
there's welfare,
so you can always just,
you know,
you can just take the welfare instead of
instead of making something of your
life,
you know,
and um,
that is what it is to kill a man when
you kill his self determination and you
kill his,
his agency and you kill his motivation
to do something with his life that is to
kill a man.
And that is what the left is doing.
And,
and I say that's about,
that is racism.
I do,
and we should say it out loud,
but we never do.
The conservatives never called it and
they should call it what it is.
Um,
and you know,
well,
what can you do?
You just gotta keep going,
right?
What a beautiful ending.
That's ending right there.
We're going to clip that one and do
something with that because that was
just part of it.
Well that this is what it's all about.
Everything that I'm trying to do here.
You're talking about the roots and the
foundation of all of that and you're
doing it and I promise you I will make
it to the school when I'm in the uk for
great.
Can I do to give a little talk?
Maybe we can do something like.
This was really a pleasure.
Thank you so much and thanks to douglas
by the way,
so we were least by Douglas Murray
douglas for more on catherine.
Follow her on twitter.
It's at miss underscore snuffy.